the first question that's come in I'm
going to direct it to pastor Randy skeet
because I believe it refers to something
that you mentioned during a few of your
presentations it came in via Twitter and
it says there's how can Jesus be God
doesn't that contradict the God the
doctrine of the Godhead Jesus is divine
the Bible is very clear in Isaiah
chapter 45 verse 18 the Bible said thus
it the law that created the heavens God
Himself that formed the earth and made
it he hath established it he created it
not in vain he formed it to be inhabited
I am the Lord and there is none else
meaning there is no one other than God
who can create now in Hebrews chapter 1
a reading from verse 8 this is God the
Father speaking let me say again God the
Father and unto the unto the son he says
thy throne O God is forever and ever a
scepter of righteousness is the scepter
of thy kingdom the father calls the son
God in verse 10 the father says and thou
Lord in the beginning has laid the
foundation of the earth and the heavens
are the works of thy hands the Bible is
very clear only God can create and God
the Father identifies Jesus as the
creator in mark two five to seven Jesus
forgave the sins of a man those sitting
by said why does this man thus speak
blasphemies who can forgive sins but God
and so it's very clear from scriptures
that Jesus is God John 11:25 I am the
resurrection and the life only God can
be that John 5 verse 40 and you will not
come to me that you might have a life
you can only get life from God the Bible
is very clear Jesus is God by that I
mean he is divine as much as the father
is divine
clear second question practical one how
can I reach out to my friends baptized
in church what participates in
activities that are not right or rather
damaging to health eg drug sex how do I
do it because they know the truth and I
don't want to come across as if I'm
judging them or have I'll have them
think I'm better than them simply
because I'm a sin to myself but I'm also
concerned
well sub 1 + it is the man that walketh
not in the counsel of the ungodly nor
standeth in the way of sinners nor
sitteth in the seat of the scornful but
his delight is in the law of the Lord
and on his law doth he meditate day and
night so you see in there a a slippin
you know you're first of all here you
know your standing in the way of sinners
and you're walking you're walking you're
standing you're sitting so you're
slowing down and you really have to the
person that asked a question you have to
ask the question really who are my
friends and am i influencing them or are
they influencing me and first of all we
sometimes will you know walk with the
ungodly and the things that you
described in your question are ungodly
and the call them ungodly is not
judgment because you're not making
judgment in terms of eternal salvation
which we're called not to do but you can
make judgment concerning you know
actions or behaviors that are sinful or
not sinful the best thing for you to do
is really your friendship with them do
what's right if they continue doing
what's wrong they're not your friends
and you need to move on however as we
you know when I became a Christian truly
a Christian I don't have any of the same
friends most of those people are
actually dead because they made
decisions that led to death
and and yet some of them are so we have
to be compassionate but we have to
follow the Lord and may I add while we
should be kind and christ-like in
everything that we do amen
there's never an occasion to be
unnecessarily hurtful or out of our way
to be difficult of course not
having said that this seems to be in my
estimation a somehow we have been
infected with this concept that if we're
just nice enough the Lord will bless
take your time everything's going to be
fine
the thing is conviction sometimes looks
like anger when you preach an
evangelistic campaign and you preach
some truth that steps on someone's toes
they're not always going to say thank
you so much I appreciate you know we're
closer now because no no no they might
get up and lead but that doesn't mean
that they're done that the Lord is
working on their heart and at some point
we have to again in a kind Christ like
Jesus loves you kind of way be clear in
our convictions be a living
demonstration of the power of God in our
lives and let there be a distinction
between light and darkness the darkness
doesn't need more darkness it needs
light to know the way out and somehow we
have to be resolute in our convictions
and if there's a separation as the Book
of Amos the Prophet tells us can two
walk together unless they be one agreed
there's a natural separation between the
righteous and the sinful while we want
to bring them along we need to be so
careful that we don't round off the
edges so that people don't see the
distinction and we now come under
condemnation for not making it clear
where they need to go okay thank you
next question third question how do we
practice good judgment practical
suggestions in John chapter 5 Jesus says
I can have mine own self do nothing as I
hear I judge and my judgment is just in
other words Christ is saying all the
assessments all the evaluations he made
of various circumstances that confronted
him was based over based on the
word of his father it is the word of God
that gives us clear and sound judgment
and so if a question is how can I judge
soundly or wisely let the Bible be the
perspective from which you view every
situation without exception God's Word
provides sound judgment but you have to
know God's Word and back up God's Word
with the Enlightenment from the counsel
of Evan white okay I'm going to move on
to the next question which says I
sometimes feel this to do with
relationships male/female it can go both
ways this question Arita assets I will
read it as if asked I sometimes feel
that women more attractive to me don't
seem to possess the characteristics I'm
searching for however women who may be
less attractive to me seem to possess
the biblical standards I'm looking for
please tell me that was an anonymous
yeah okay I Lucia how important should
looks be in choosing a partner who
excels in all other areas
pastor skeet would it be safe to say
that there's a correlation here to the
dressing for beautiful holiness and for
beauty it's important too
I have a wife and she is gorgeous amen
inside and out
right but the inside Trump's the out
every time and twice on Sunday if you
understand what I'm saying
the inside is you look at Peters council
let not your adorning be with the
outward right but with the inward the
quiet the christ-like spirit and what is
he going to say for this is how women of
old made themselves beautiful there's
nothing wrong with beauty there's
nothing wrong with beauty I appreciate
pastor Skeets you know we should not go
out of our way somehow we've gotten this
idea that inward beauty needs to be
demonstrated by outward ugly yeah am i
saying truth today
yeah okay but I miss by the way mrs.
white has clear counsel on this as well
we should we should be respectable we
should be decent we should be clean we
should be modest we should be wholesome
we should be we should look sharp but
let that outward be merely an extension
a reflection of the true inward
character there's christ-like and can
only come from him you know the other
thing is that usually people that are
good-looking are pretty aware of that
and that's why they that's why they act
so ungodly mmm and I got to tell you my
wife is actually the most beautiful
woman in the world and she has become
more and more beautiful to me because of
those character qualities and
characteristics
I had a man from Jamaica once so he says
hot love no good for a man you need the
love that grows and grows and that's the
kind of love I have in my
all right we're glad glad someone say
Amen um following the sermon from Pastor
skeet is there any hope for those that
did not consult God in choosing a Korea
there was hope for Jonah oh yeah where
there was over Jonah yes of course there
is now understand this fundamental
principle the original path God has for
you
no Christian service page 9 paragraph 3
Alawite writes a distinct work is
assigned to every Christian manuscript
releases vol 14 page 205 paragraph 4 to
each human being God has assigned an
individuality and a distinct work now
God's riches and sweetest blessings are
to be found in the ideal path he has
chosen for you if you do not follow that
path and you fall an alternate path now
God does not abandon you but the
blessings you would receive in God's
original choice you cannot enjoy in your
alternate choice but God doesn't abandon
you he could still use you it was not
God's choice for Samson to run after
prostitutes and end up the way he did
but the Lord did not abandon him so
depending on your age you can always say
father with the rest of the time I have
helped me to redeem the time show me
what you would have me to do and it's
amazing what God will do with you from
the point on which you acknowledge
father I depend on you completely he can
do miracles with you but ideally you
should get into the path God has chosen
for you as soon as possible well any you
think about it from this perspective sin
itself was never God's ideal for us was
it but was there hope for us of course
there is redemption that's the whole
plan right and in the analogy of when a
bone is broken you know it heals at that
break stronger than it has been
originally now does that mean that there
we should therefore extend that and make
every bone broken so we can no no no no
the ideal is still
ever have a break but where sin abounds
grace abounds all the more and so we
serve a God of redemption and what your
mistakes can turn into a testimony that
he can use to your glory as well
the question is do you recognize it and
get on the right Road when he shows you
the way thank you how can I tell the
Holy Spirit is talking how can you tell
the Holy Spirit is talking to you the
Holy Spirit convicts of sin and
righteousness and judgment to come so
when you feel a conviction maybe you're
angered at something that's being
brought forth by God's Word and that
anger can actually be a sign of
conviction so it convicts of sin
thankfully it doesn't just in there it
also convicts of righteousness so you
can say you know that's the right thing
I can see logically and God uses reason
come let us reason together so he he's
reasonable and then judgment to come
there's this sense of you know what I'd
better do this this is something I need
to do this is the operative factor and
health evangelism people are convicted
of sin they realize that what they're
doing is wrong and they see what the
right thing is to do and they need to do
something about it and that's the
principle of leading people from health
to him when they see that that's why
health evangelism is actually a work of
the Holy Spirit and it is frontline
evangelism it's it's wonderful to see
Randy skeet can you please come back
next year
if it's God's will and even invite me I
always tell them first pray first he may
not want me
God has hundreds of servants he may want
somebody else so pray if you're
convicted I am the one then God will
make the way but don't just speak me
because you like the right dress or the
sound of my voice you Pig as the Lord
directs kill somebody say amen amen
why is it when a girl gets pregnant
outside marriage girls usually get
censored while the boy doesn't and in
some churches whether or not people get
censored depends on who you are what
position your family holds surely this
is not fair and the way the church shuns
and kicks you when you at your lowest
spiritually where is the love surely
there is no place for favoritism I just
think we should just agree with that and
move on we agree with you the biggest
problem with the church is is full of
people yeah and people inherently stink
God makes us better but we're all in
here and so even even within even within
leadership you need to pray for them be
kind and gracious to them and expect
more as the Lord continues to lead them
but they're absolutely right hypocrisy
is rampant and it is a real problem and
it needs to be addressed but agree and
move on yeah I was baptized at a very
young age at the time I did not know the
full meaning I did not even have take
the lessons for baptism do I need to be
rebaptised or is it a matter of
recommitting to the Lord daily I'd
encourage you to be baptized because you
never really understood and baptisms
supposed to come at the time that you
understand we believe in adult baptism
and people are baptized when they're in
their full and right mind so be baptized
I'm happy to talk to you about that okay
this second question relates to baptism
as well so I'll ask it now baptism erea
baptism guilt I was baptized last year
since then I've fallen by getting close
with someone who's married yes hold this
hold comments I was being a friend at
the time and things changed we've never
had sex but we have kissed I have
stopped it since but the guilt has been
weighing on me my question is what
should I do
should I get rebaptised or rebuild my
life with the repentance I guess the the
I think the council is this there's a
couple of points but there's two
chapters and testimonies five erroneous
and true views of confession and in that
those two chapters Ellen White's very
clear that we should confess things
openly that are open and we should
publicly take care of the things that
are open and then some things that are
private we should keep to ourselves
because it doesn't help us and it
doesn't help others and I don't know
what this particular situation is but if
others have seen that you're cozying up
to this person and they've seen these
different things you need to publicly
acknowledge that and you need to go
forward and publicly recommit in your
life to the Lord if it's a more private
nature you still need to have a you know
confession before God and before any
that have been influenced by that and
you need to rededicate your life and a
special communion service but if you've
been you've been publicly messing around
this is a problem and for this gentleman
who's involved this is a very heinous
act and if I was your pastor I would
call you out on that and so with the
board of elders that is just not
acceptable especially with someone new
to the faith or anyone early
kind of going on from that I believe God
forgives but how does one forgive
themself and let go the Bible doesn't
call upon us to forgive ourselves as far
as I know the Bible calls upon us to
accept God's forgiveness and it has
nothing to do with how you feel
there isn't a feeling component with
faith faith is based on the absolutely
reliable Word of God first John 1:9 says
if we confess our sins he is faithful
and just to forgive us our sins and to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness
anyone who fully accepts God's
forgiveness will have no consideration
of do I forgive myself God's forgiveness
takes care of all of that so we accept
his forgiveness
based on the infinite sacrifice of
Christ only God can forgive sins you
really can't forgive your sin or
somebody else's you accept God's
forgiveness fully and freely this is a
huge question in depression recovery
this comes all the time people not
forgiving themselves and what you've
said is correct I love this text first
John 3:24 if our heart condemns us God
is greater than our heart and knows all
things amen how do you know when you're
called to ministry I'm struggling with
what I want to do and I felt like I'm
being pulled towards a ministry but I am
NOT a confident speaker did you say what
was the last part not a confidence I'm
sure you yeah so it's been call to
ministry but I'm struggling what I want
to do I felt like I'm being pulled
toward ministry but I'm not a confident
speaker well I guess the definition of
ministry in this person's mind is being
able to publicly speak but there's all
kinds of ministries and there's all
kinds of gifts and you speak by the way
you do God's ordained ministry to you
there are things that you're called to
that are not your role and some you have
to let the Lord define what the role is
that you're called to there's a
difference between gifts and
and offices for instance and this is a
confusion in the church today but I
believe everyone is called to ministry
everyone according to Ephesians 4 is
called to ministry and so nobody in this
room should should not follow the
calling of God to ministry yeah that to
me to me that's it's been a study of
mine recently is it's very it seems that
some idea has crept in to our ranks
somehow that if I want to win souls for
Christ then I must be called to the
ministry and if I'm not called the
ministry I must not win souls we the
pastor's job is to get members to do
their job okay the pastor's job is to
get members to do their job and every
member is called to be a missionary
every person should have a call on their
life to minister to someone else in some
capacity now is it necessarily in the
office of the pastor not necessarily and
the Bible gives qualifications for that
and the Bible should be the filter that
but in case you don't meet those
biblical qualifications you say well I
guess that I have no role image no no
you're called to minister every everyone
in this room should have someone there
studying the Bible with right now and
you don't need a license you don't need
credential you don't need ordination for
that you need a Bible and the Spirit of
God saying go win a soul and to what
we've created is an unbiblical
distinction between there's the people
out there and there we have it we have a
world full of Watchers instead of a
church full of workers right we think
well I must win souls therefore I'm
called to be a pastor slow down you're
called to win souls now if the Lord
wants to put you in the office of Pastor
continue to study that out but if you
feel the burden on your heart to
minister minister and if you turns that
into full-time ministry continue to
watch for his leadings compared to the
scriptures look at the look at the
results the fruits of your labor look at
the qualifications of Bible look to
those who long expiry
and they will help you in that but if
you have the call of God on your life
right now to minister to others Minister
okay thank you thank you how do you
overcome loneliness I've been living on
my own since the age of 60 and I'm 22
without family
nor the love that I longed for and every
day I misunderstood and don't feel like
I fit in anywhere but I know in God I
will find love and peace the older I get
the harder the struggle help so
essentially how do I overcome loneliness
well one thing is if you want to have
friends show yourself friendly get
yourself out of the out of the cage it
sounds like you might have a little bit
of depression and your social I socially
isolating yourself and I think the psalm
that best helps in this is Psalm 77 it
shows the steps to isolation and it
shows the steps from isolation so in
Psalm 77 it gets down I won't read the
whole song but I just refer you to it to
verse 10 which sounds like you it says I
said this is my anguish in other words
you're you're carrying the whole burden
on your on yourself well the reason you
got there is because of verse 1 through
9 but the way out is verse 10 through 20
I will there's these I will statements I
will remember the Lord I will remember
your wonders of old I will meditate on
your work I will do this I will do that
it tells you exactly what to do and when
that happens you come out of that
depression and to integrated life and
your focus is not so much on yourself
but on God and others so Psalm 77 is key
now if you're here today and you need a
little more counseling talk to me come
to me I'm the guy with the mismatched
suit just come and find me and we'll
talk okay what's the best way to bridge
the gap between health
and introduce Christ there is no gap
between health and introducing Christ
that's a misnomer of a question because
when you have ill health
that's a conviction so the big problem
in the Adventist Church is that we see a
gap between those two when there really
is not a gap we just have to become more
aware of how the Holy Spirit is working
I have a whole series on that called
leading people from health to him and
I'd refer you to that or again if you
want to talk to me I'll give you some
more specifics but certainly the
connection is pronounced we we have a
four full month course too so the
connection between those two
but basically put when you think that
you have ill health that's a that's a
confession and a conviction of sin and
then God leads you to repentance how to
stop and reverse that and so there is
really no disconnection between those
two okay this one came in via text isn't
it is it an acceptable practice to God
to substitute clapping in church for
amen what is the biblical and Spirit
prophecy teaching and references on this
matter there is a an office of the
church called the biblical research
institute one of their functions their
primary function is to research Bible
questions and provide answers to the
various church committees when they vow
to make decisions they study the issue
of clapping in the Bible they concluded
there is no biblical evidence that
clapping was used as a part of worship
none
okay say one other thing quickly if
someone passes by on the outside without
seeing what is going on in a building
and they hear clapping they may think
well someone's performing if they hear
Amen what will they think service okay
would you enlightened Li kindly
enlighten me on the biblical teaching
SDA position on dancing in church is
there an acceptable and unacceptable
dance during worship of any kind
patriarchs and prophets page 709 the
music and dancing in joyful praise to
God at the removal of the ark had not
the faintest resemblance to the
dissipation of modern dancing the one
tended to the remembrance of God and
exalted his holy name and the other is a
decisive Satan one of the problems with
us we do not know what it means to be a
set of the adventist we just have no
clue and so we try to be Pentecostals or
we try to be Baptists or we try to be
somebody else we try to be everything
except one hundred percent set of the
Adventist and so we bring these things
from other churches into our church
trying to be like them not pausing to
think they never take anything from us
to be like us we're trying to be like
them listen to me if you study the
history of this church and the mission
of this church and the teaching of this
church you will be personally insulted
by any attempt to make this church like
another Church I was in Bermuda and I
was at a dinner with a family and one
person present was a former Baptist or
Pentecostal something and she said when
she came she came in to church with just
a few years ago she were shocked she
said I thought I had left that she says
she saw the damned see all the waving of
hands during singing and people jumping
up she saw all she said that is what I
left that's a terrible thing when it is
right wants to be an Egyptian okay thank
you for those answers with so few men in
church
think someone stood up today and said it
was 18 to 1 I don't know what statistic
but anyway I did call the NEC secretary
and found out that the official books
for the NEC is 2 to 1
all ages all ages that's not delineating
youth or does it deter okay haven't
anyway with so few men in church can I
still wait on the Lord focus in on my
ministry in Korea or should I take a
more proactive approach searching the
highways and byways of the Adventist
Church so this the sister is tempted to
make matchmaking the career at least her
career I don't know a biblical precedent
for that I can tell you that in my own
experience my wife and I did not get
married until we were each 30 years old
we we discovered each other in college
in uni and I was not the man I should
have been I was someone to be apparently
interested in talked with but I was not
the one you marry uh and I praise the
Lord
that through His grace alone he
maintained our non married status for
each other so that when the Lord had
done a better work in me or I had
allowed him to do work in me that he had
wanted to do all along that when the
time and occasion was correct we were
there I praise the Lord that my wife did
not settle or lower the bar or
compromise in any way so that when the
right time was there the wrong decisions
have been made and the opportunity was
lost so I would encourage and I promise
you if you were to talk with her she
would encourage all of you single men or
women regardless to be patient to wait
on the Lord and let him do his work in
you as he likely is doing in that
corresponding person you know I'd say
something to the young
men here there are some nice young
ladies here you should get to know if
God's leading don't think that you're
going to put off things and your freedom
is better than being married the I mean
I didn't get married till I was 29 - and
I had to wait for five years for my wife
and pastor randon also had a similar
chronology as we know Patran devasher
the divisor is also indicated that the
final movements for rapid but which
means these make the case that you can
wait but the other thing I'd say is
sometimes we have this delusion as young
people that single life is better than
the married life and it is if you marry
the wrong person which is about what
you're ready to do if you go out looking
and shopping and hop in yourself let God
lead in it the worst thing is to marry
somebody that God didn't want you to
marry you want you want to have more
misery than you have now
do that there's not one marriage in a
hundred Ella white says that are have
the sanction of God and they're not
happy and I talk to people every day who
have terrible marriages so praise the
Lord you're not married yet because you
didn't marry the wrong person and let
God lead you to the right person and
you're worrying about the wrong thing
God is not concerned with how many men
or women are they your question must be
am i faithful to God do I have a
one-to-one relationship with God if you
do God will find someone for you don't
worry about demographics and I mean
women are nothing new conference ordered
it off whereas conference I am a son of
God if marriage is God's will from me
and I'm faithful to God as I do the
Lord's will God will find the right
woman for me or the right man for me if
I'm God's daughter you need to have a
personal individual not a sociological
relation
a personal Elijah said I'm the only one
faithful God said no no no they are what
7,000 more we've not bowed the knee you
just have not seen them
God knows where they are and if they
don't exist God who made Adam will make
one for you so don't worry be faithful
to God and God the Bible says no good
thing with you withhold from them that
walk uprightly the Bible says he defined
it for why find if a good thing so be
faithful to God but him first in all you
do and watch God provide for you
miraculously I mean not all Adventists
believe in the authority the spirit of
prophecy what would you suggest as a
strategy for reaching them any books you
would recommend well several years ago I
had dr. Colin Campbell come to my church
he's the probably one of the persons
that had the most research grants
granted by higher education he wrote a
book called the China Study before he
came I sent him a bunch of statements by
Ellen White concerning health issues he
wrote back to me and he said I know of
no statements that you've sent me that
are wrong and have not been backed up by
the scientific evidence over the last
thirty years so I am convinced that this
message of Ellen White that has been
mislaid or not being shared by Adventist
needs to be shared with as many people
as possible so people in the world today
at least in the area of health are
recognizing the Ellen White
well it's not only ahead of her time
she's an authority the reason that we as
Adventists are known as people for
longevity is because there were a group
of people in the administer to actually
took Ellen White's words believe them
that founded the basis for Adventist
Health Study one and two and now three
how many of you are thankful for the
people that actually believed it
so what I do typically is I will show
all the scientific evidence and then I
will say and notice what Ellen White
said because what I wanting to do is win
that person to take a second look it's
an embarrassment that we have to do that
but and then the other thing I will do
is the more I've studied Ellen White the
more I realize that she's just basically
sharing the Bible so what I will do is I
will share the Bible and I will share
the exegesis and whatnot and I'll sweat
really hard and then I will say well
usually later on in the message and this
is why I believe Ellen White says so if
you're trying to win something with
Ellen White that doesn't believe Ellen
White don't start with Ellen White start
with the Bible and show how she is in
accordance with the Bible and start with
science and so how she's in accordance
with it
okay thank you ken nurses and doctors
work on Sabbath serving people's lives
of course the question is should they
get paid when I worked as a nurse my
wife was working in the hospital as well
she said Don I never take money on the
Sabbath because Jesus didn't take money
he didn't heal someone and said I'm the
master where is your MasterCard so you
know that really got me so I began
thinking about that and I noticed that
that was true and so I began giving away
all my money then I got on the Sabbath
if I had to work because people are sick
on the Sabbath they need to be cared for
that was such a joyous experience and I
had people then lining up because when
they saw my car they knew I was going to
give away money on the Sabbath one day I
came and there were 65 people waiting to
get money from me and this little kid
when I was driving down the road he goes
he's here I was one of the days I felt
the most like Jesus and so I was giving
the money out and they called from
upstairs they said please come upstairs
the head nurse came and down and I had
to go up and she goes came upstairs and
I said did I do something wrong she goes
you know we really like you I said that
sounds like girls that have broken up
with me what are you about to say
she said we have watched you and we see
that you give away all your money we
give you made on the Sabbath so we have
decided something so what's that she
goes I don't want you to work in the
hospital from sundown Friday to sundown
Saturday Wow anyway the point is if you
are working on Sabbath which we need to
do at times to take care of the sick
question your own motives don't be in
vegetarian rebellion taking double
shifts on the Sabbath making all kinds
of money now I preached this sermon I
use this in a sermon at my church and
the doctors in my congregation were so
convicted that they turned in the money
that they had been making in about two
weeks later I had eighty five thousand
dollars in a fund it grew to one hundred
and sixty thousand dollars and all those
physicians then begin not accepting
money on the Sabbath as well and that
kept them honest yes we need to serve
people on the Sabbath that are sick but
we also need to purify our own motives
thank you clear answer where do you
stand on women being ordained as pastors
while the churches and study of that
there's actually been a theology of
ordination Study Committee so-called
Tosk
you can google it and the church has
been in studying now for two years on
that I'm on that committee and that
committee how has it being that
committee has been we would put it this
way very intense and I think there are
passionate god-fearing people who stand
on both sides of the issue it really
comes down to how they read the writings
of Paul in first Timothy and in first
corinthians 11 and 14 and in titus and
how they look at the example of Christ
and the Apostles as well as the early
Adventist Church there are three
positions that have come out of that
committee one is basically saying
maintain the position the Adventist
Church has had since its inception which
is to ordain only men to the office of
pastor minister the second position has
been that we change from the position of
the church and this reading of scripture
and allow various divisions to go their
own way in terms of ordination practice
and third kind of hybrid position has
said we believe that men should be
leaders in the home in the church but we
believe there might be exceptions where
the holy spirit leaves otherwise so they
attempt to maintain what's happening
what kind of a status quo things so
those are the three positions you know I
don't know what the position of this
conference or you are individually my my
own I don't know if you want me to share
my own feeling on it but my own feeling
is there are a couple shocking things
that came out of the committee to me
number one it was clearly stated by the
historians of the church that there
never has been the ordination of women
in the official ordination of women in
the Adventist Church to the position of
pastor minister ever in the history of
the Adventist Church if
people want to look that up those
resources available yes right that's a
paper David trims that's a paper by
David trim it's on the task website
some people said before I went there the
information I got especially in North
America was that there had been many
women ordained simply not true second
big thing that really impacted me was
they said well it wasn't the time to
ordain people at that time not too many
people were ordaining people and Ellen
White and the church would have gotten
in trouble that also is completely
untrue there were 27 denominations that
begin to ordaining women during the time
of Ellen White and it was in that milieu
that the church in 1881 specifically
said no and did not go that way when I
learned that I was like whoa that's
fairly interesting information the third
thing that was really interesting to me
that came out of Tosk was that the
largest Protestant denomination in the
world was is the Southern Baptist came
to a time in their church's history
where they were looking at this issue
and there were a lot of people calling
for ordination in fact they had 1,000
women ordained as pastors in their
church but when they studied the
biblical evidence they realized that
they didn't want to go that way and they
reversed course that is the largest
Protestant denomination in the world at
this time and they took a stand on that
on the basis of the very text that the
Adventist Church is studying so you know
each of us will have to grapple with
that each of our leaders will have to
grapple with that right what happens now
is that those recommendations that came
from the Tosk committee now go to the
higher levels of administration in the
Adventist Church they frame how that
question then will go forth forward at a
group of meetings called the annual
Council which is when a bunch of the top
administrators and whatnot from around
the world get together and then they
frame what question will go or questions
will go before the General Conference in
2015 how many of you will want to keep
that in prayer if you have any other
specific questions about the ordination
thing because we want to we don't want
to take more time on that
seemi I've been thinking about that for
about two years thank you if the wages
of sin is death which Jesus died for
should he then have remained dead
evermore as a sacrifice regardless of
death not being able to hold him as
having himself never sinned if he lives
has the death been paid one of the
difficult things that we face as 7th
avenues is we have so much truth that
often times we are tempted to think that
we can understand everything and so we
venture into speculation if this were to
happen then what would have happened
right the premise of the question is you
know basically one of those speculative
questions if this was really the thing
wouldn't Christ have not and then if
Christ really would have died and what
does that really mean for God to die and
then what would have happened to the
Godhead and how could he have been a
risen Savior if we needed a mediator
after I mean it unleashes a Pandora's
box of speculation that the scripture
doesn't give us light on I believe that
Jesus was God I believe that Jesus was
man I believe that Christ died and the
closest thing we can come to a death in
the Godhead if you would is mrs. White's
statement about there will never be
another Sundering of the Godhead but as
pastors keep so very clearly Christ laid
down his life voluntarily but then he
picked it back up how did he do it I
don't know but I believe it because
God's Word says so I believe it because
it because it is that it is the
declaration of Scripture and that is my
basis of faith will I ever understand
how God operates what it means to be
life not just to be alive but to be life
itself
I cannot say one thing you know Ellen
White clearly states and I believe the
Bible teaches that Christ died the
second death he didn't die the first
death he died the second death which was
an out point of the wrath
got against sin I believe that
Revelation 16 which is a picture of the
seven last plagues can be reread and
applied actually to what Christ did for
us each one of those is related to a
sanctuary truth and when Jesus died he
said it is finished at the end of
Revelation 16 it says it is done we live
between the it is finished and the it is
done Christ paid the full debt and the
full and took the whole wrath of God and
he went through Calvary he went through
the separation and all the different
aspects Isaiah 53 talks about which are
associated with the outpouring of the
fullness of wrath now we believe that
death is asleep an eternal sleep it's
not an eternal torment so the issue of
time really doesn't even make it's
really not even it doesn't make sense it
doesn't have anything to do with paying
the debt when you're dead you're dead
okay and Christ was dead he did not see
through the portals of the tomb humanity
died so that's the way I look at that
salvation requires death and life in
John 1:29 the Bible says behold the lamb
of God which taketh away the sins of the
world Jesus is the lamb Hebrews 4:15 we
have not an High Priest which cannot be
touched with the feeling of our
infirmities he's bought the lamb he's
moved a priest the lamb dies the priest
ministers the merits of that sacrifice
so Jesus had to come from the grave in
order to minister to us the merits of
that death you understand what I'm
trying to say
in Revelation 1:17 the Bible says when I
saw him I fell at his feet as dead and
he laid his right hand upon me saying
unto me fear not I'm the first and the
last I am he that liveth and was dead
and behold I am Alive for evermore so
Jesus himself said I was dead that's
correct
he said I now live now I'm not about to
argue with Jesus because he is the way
the truth and the life and so salvation
requires death but it also requires life
because a dead God can
not save you amen how can one overcome
self-righteousness how can you know
which voices in your head are from the
Holy Spirit or the devil without them
being blatant that the same question
well let's go with the first part okay
how can I overcome self-righteousness
read Isaiah 53 except Li says if you
want to know humility and
self-righteousness and humility I like
black and white read Isaiah 53 now I'm
suggesting also study Philippians 2:5
2:8 study the life of Christ die rages
desire of Ages and you cannot be a
self-righteous person but keep studying
it because it crops right back up yeah
you noticed that while we shun
appropriately enough once saved always
said we somehow have imbibed once
learned always learned that oh I read
that one time and it is kind of fades
away and apparently we're supposed to
abide in him dwell in him continually
and these themes will continue to
re-emerge as do our sinful proclivities
and the Lord has a remedy for them and
it is written but we need to be in the
word for that to be happening okay I
think this may be the last question how
do you study and memorize the Bible and
enjoy it to the point of committing all
those verses to memory question 1
question 2 I find the Bible boring to
read and struggle to understand it
please help me to love and able to
understand the Bible
so the first question is memorization of
Scripture look scripture memorization is
is kind of the key to meditation if you
want to learn anything if you're in
school for any discipline it requires a
certain level of memory for mastery
everybody knows that it doesn't matter
if you're in be off biology theology
education so everything single thing you
do whether it's music ministry or
anything else it demands memory and the
more into something that you are the
more given you are to memorizing it so I
would just say that's the principle and
then the second thing is you're not
saved by your memory the Bible says that
God will bring things to your
remembrance so when you see someone that
has a good memory of Scripture that's
God bringing things to their remembrance
that's not them and I remember I live
with my grandfather and he was
developing Alzheimer's and organic brain
simmer and I used to didn't understand
that really fully then and I was kind of
almost criticizing him for not
remembering one day he looked at me he
said Don if I needed to remember that
God would bring it to my remembrance and
I kind of backed off then but in uncanny
thing was that even though he was almost
developing Alzheimer's he could remember
all of the things from the spirit of
prophecy in the Bible and he would often
quote them to me to correct me and God
brought them to remembrance to someone
who was even developing Alzheimer's but
he can't bring something to your
remembrance that you didn't originally
memorize so get busy memorizing and I
think that's the key the second thing to
what you focus on you fall in love with
amen we haven't been able to do all the
questions time is not with us we were
moving into our next worship service in
just a few moments I want to thank each
one of the panelists amen for their
answers if your question was not
answered and you're able to catch them
at a free time sometime
today then you're more than welcome to
approach them we'll try and get answers
to those with textin or came on Twitter
as well we'll try and get back to you
through those modes before we do sit
down though it some I think I'll take
advantage of the moment that we do have
all of our speakers here on the stage at
the same time and they're all going to
be busy in different aspects so the rest
of the day and we may not see them all
together one place at one time
and so as on behalf of the youth
department of the North England
conference I would like to thank each
and every one of them
pastor Cameron Devesh afore his series
this week on the Greek controversy that
he's going to conclude today has been
powerful has been clear would like to
thank you Pastor camera for coming here
with your wife and your two children
it's not easy traveling with a family
and if you knew his schedule before he
came to camp meet and he knew his
schedule after camp meeting he literally
squeezed us right in some people would
even say he was a little bit mad to take
this appointment we want to thank him
for taking it and pray that God would
give him health and strength and grace
in his future ministry Thank You Cameron
for coming in for ministering to us and
we really appreciate that
and your family pastor dawn as well
thank you very much for being here for
giving us the health presentations
throughout the week for your time on the
panel as well today I'd like to thank
you for bringing yourself and your wife
and your children your children for
coming bringing them here to
camp-meeting thank you for coming for
serving and for ministering and we'd
also like to thank pastor Randy ski for
coming here for sacrificing time
elsewhere to come here and minister to
us here in the North England conference
the messages have been powerful they've
been clear and we'd like to thank each
one of you thank you very much all of
their messages they have given are
available will be available online on
the podcast or on the NEC YouTube
channel you can watch them on demand
later after camp-meeting share them with
your family share them with your friends
Thank You amen